hello muck consider lobby gamespot's
weekly hang out every tuesday at two
p.m. pacific right here on video games
com i'm your host on your wire how are
you doing I'm doing great i'm sitting
here with diet and peter brown and
suburban tay hey you gentlemen how's
your weekend I don't know too sorry
suburban Eric would like to say that I
it was a fun filled weekend for me I
watched a lot of evo 2015 knows a lot of
hype a lot of emotion it was draining
just like not even playing just watching
it it was draining um and yeah that's
kind of my weekend yeah so when they did
was when did he will start Friday okay
and I ran all weekend as I could see if
my twitter feed just people freaking out
and posting gifts and pictures of Jamie
Lee Curtis and stuff for the people who
don't know for those who don't watch evo
so what is bebo it's been around forever
and I like 20 years ago almost mmm yeah
it is the premier fighting game
tournament in the world I mean people
from all over Japan the United States
anywhere you name it they show up to
play games like street fighter for
mortal kombat is in there marvel vs
capcom 3 all sorts of stuff eating
Catherine guilty gear Catherine yeah
Catherine the single player love game
there is a like a head-to-head puzzle
mode I think okay with that yeah I
missed that segment but where is it do
okay yeah so everyone comes in plays big
prize pool big many spectators i can
never tell cause it's always seems to be
in that same room is it in that same
room every year I don't know this so the
the venue is a venue that was picked
from two years ago it was at Bally's it
is a ballroom like you said it looked
kind of more jam-packed this year it
will Stanley really feel like if you
look at it there you see and that's just
the front of the house and it's just
packed like the and it's packed it's
like it's packed full of like the people
who are super deep into the fighting
game community so instead there's like
no fair weather fans it seems like yeah
these events like everyone's going crazy
yeah where you know speaks English it's
all colloquialisms are all talking about
foot seas and zoning but I mean it's
it's kind of like there are multiple big
tournaments during the year but this is
kind
the Super Bowl this is like the roads
con of fighting games this is like the
III of fighting games this is where
everyone that's been training all year
like this is the big one if you win this
one it's like you get the prestige yes
you get the prize money has been going
up steadily in the last couple years but
it's more about the prestigious saying i
was the evo champion of said game and
that's really the big deal there so you
get all the sponsors to give you money
to wear their logos on your shirt right
because and also you get a bunch of
there's a lot more priced it seems at
least in terms of us like the mainstream
not in fighting a community price seems
to like hone in on this one a lot more
I'm because of that there's also a bunch
of announcements to tend to happen at
this that made up wouldn't happen
another fighting game events so what are
some of the stuff that came out of evo
2015 there's that new street fighter 5
character he is wait he's like a mix of
Blanca and and who else he looks real
weird yeah I don't know like an able but
not really because he has a command grab
but like that's like me use me saying
that he's like able just because he has
one command grab isn't really fair but
what sounds like step he's like Seth
he's like Seth and Blanca okay anyway
yeah members name nuh Kali yes great yes
great play with pretty that I'm pretty
sure that's right which is Aztec for
battle I believe sure that's what I'm
bringing to the table that's all I got I
mean guys take anymore so why is
nonsense he looks like that what was
that Ninja Theory game oh we saw uh yeah
yeah yeah yeah it looks like heavenly
sword night lady there is apparently
like an anime or comic or manga or
something that has a guy that looks very
so really yeah the hair and every season
yeah red threads I don't know it looks
like somebody to see at the gathering
anyway he's coming when is 345 coming
out next year you're saying murder I
don't have a date for 2016 but they've
unveiled the beta plans I think you like
phase 1 2 and 3 they kind of have like
rough dates the first phase of beta is
actually thursday 23 2013 alright well
they're gonna be dripping at
announcements we also saw a new game
from seth killian i saw you posting
footage of this on Monday morning tell
us a little bit about it yes we both
played a bit of it it's called rising
thunder and you know if you're just sort
of watching it it looks like street
fighter 4 with robots it has the same
sort of animations a lot of the same
move ty
oops and even camera movements during
super moves but what really sets this
game apart from any game you could
compare it to is the fact that move
lists have been sort of reduced to
simple inputs so every special move is
just done with a single button press
right you don't to do a quarter quarter
circle forward and then a button and the
thinking there is that what makes a
fighting game so interesting especially
to watch and to play is the mind games
that you play right like thinking you
know your opponent's going to do or
duping them into thinking they know what
you're going to do when really they
don't so that element is is retained but
what by simplifying the move list they
make it so that pretty much anyone can
get in and and start playing and not be
discouraged by the fact that they don't
have six months to train and write a
single character to learn that one move
and make sure you get it every time how
do you think the fighting game community
has reacted to that because there is
sort of like a there's a wonder and a
prestige in like having that like high
level of play like I loved it when I
played CS a lot that it was difficult
game that if you're in just something
like FPS scrub and you came in and
started playing CS you got your ass
handed to you I think with the people
who are compared are people who are
complaining about this game but I think
they're missing the point it's that yes
a specific move may be easier to pull
off but we are going up against somebody
who understands the characters and the
system so well just having that made
easier isn't going to make you a winner
you still have to learn to use those
moves effectively you still have to
learn a combo and you have to learn how
to read your opponent so yeah there are
people complaining other people are
intrigued and interested but the biggest
problem I I see with this and the
reaction of the article I wrote is there
is no local versus all right raley it's
online only and that's because some of
the things they have designed if you see
the meter down on the left that's your
cool down so you can't spam those
one-button specials right so that
prevents that but if you were to be
playing against other player you could
see their meter and that would give away
when they're able to do their move again
so by playing online each player has
their own meter they can't see their
opponents and that creates interesting
matchups but that's happening at the
cost of local you know competition is
yes that's kind of weird that's why
you'll they just take that stuff that
does this game out microtransactions uh
yes people online no well so it is free
to play there are micro transactions but
no gameplay is hidden behind it ok it's
only Kozma
but yeah I mean the game is so really
early they're taking alpha signups right
now all the character models like apart
from maybe one or two textures I'm
seeing art textured so the game is going
to continue to look better there's going
to be a lot more characters announced
and released and yeah I mean I actually
think this game is a brilliant move I
don't know that the fighting game
community is going to really rally
behind it but I think it's a good step
in the right direction to open up
fighting games to a larger audience sure
it's it doesn't seem like it's stepping
on anyone's toes necessarily yeah when
is rising Thunder I've have they given
any inclination probably next year well
the Alpha is gonna start I think in a
couple weeks time um and then from there
it's just going to be an evolving thing
it's not really coming out necessarily
so I'm going to be growing cool looking
forward seeing more of that and getting
back to evo we're used to celebrities
jumping on the videogame training and
saying yeah I play video games will
arnett into his video games he actually
I think co-produced had max hazard game
which was very terrible yeah well yeah
but over the weekend we saw some sort of
bizarre news that not only was Jamie Lee
Curtis fam talking in an interview last
week about how much he loved street
fighter but her and her entire family
cosplay to evo yeah is that the weirdest
take you've ever heard for like
celebrities at an event I did she I
could turn it up an EVO it's only weird
that she's because she's a celebrity
right okay I don't know I think it's her
cousin well I like on the face of it
it's weird because she's celebrity she's
a woman and because she's not young
either you know there's like there's to
me she doesn't fit the gen then like not
what we would perceive as the normal
fighting game fan or at least what I
would maybe it's my own bias oh sure
coming it's player I mean yeah because
she's so popular it's a good
representation of people and different
demographics showing up but I guarantee
you there are plenty of people who don't
fit the standard demographic that are
there that aren't getting the attention
rice yes so cool Jamie Lee Curtis that's
great but if I'm honest like I think I
don't know I'd rather see the other
faces who are there that don't already
have that celebrity bomb yeah pretty
cool that you decided to cover her face
up so she can actually enjoy yeah she
that the cosplay was there to kind of
hide the fact that she could just enjoy
it and not have to worry about it so at
one fun one thing she might have enjoyed
is a particularly funny early
celebration Eric Taylor I've only seen a
short YouTube of this
you give us some sort of context it's
like these there's this Mario's telling
me there's like this subreddit where
they just have videos of Ernie
celebrations going bad like cyclists
signature defrost we like it whoo and
then they like fall over some jerks like
pasta what happened here so i believe it
was guilty gear sir door xrd I can't say
it right but basically he thinks he wins
here in winner Sammy's he thinks he's
done won the match he's going to grand
finals he's celebrating he's excited
guess what you only wanted one round
buddy and his opponent you know just
goes in and destroys him because he's
like great walk away you know we're in a
competition yeah I'm not gonna and then
watch this this is the greatest part
though he's like yeah I'm the man good
man son and he goes off for a while it's
pretty funny I mean this even made
Sports Centre for ESPN really yeah which
is crazy yeah on Justin yeah I don't
think he's ever celebrated in his life
no mean is now to do it but this is part
of the cool thing about evo I think is
that some some of these players that
have been training all year if they can
make it far enough all eyes are on them
yeah and you know if they can win a
really exciting like emotionally
draining match like you see all the pop
off switch is like when they get super
excited like turn around they're like
yeah like I freaking beat that guy were
like you you didn't think that guy would
beat someone else and then the crowd
just goes crazy and there's a lot of
that dudes pulling off their shirts
before they fight and stuff oh that's
right so great yeah so good to explain
that um so punko is a street fighter
player who can't they just have real
names you just call them by likes so
pouco is known for taking off his shirt
dr. the korean guy okay he's known for
like when he takes off his shirt he
powers up and so this guy I don't even
know who he is some random decides you
know I lost the first rat of my first
match we have one more I'm gonna talk
about I don't think so any almost double
perfect sim oh really almost double peas
him oh like I guess shoutouts to that
guy for you know even bringing that up
because that's like he gets his claim to
fame from that but you got destroyed
that's true oh yeah this is a certain
I really enjoy that sort of fun
one-on-one like boasting it's kind of
like UFC or boxing where people just
open each other's faces and so much of
me sports it's like so regimented and
boring like you got your dota team over
here and you're the guys over here don't
look at each other's screens yeah and
whereas in this it's just like just two
people you know up against each other
and but that's what whatever goes go
just go back to rising Thunder what
you're describing right there is what
made fighting games so much fun like
they yeah they were born in the arcades
strangers facing off against each other
like rubbing elbows you know
accelerating and seeing that like either
you're a loser or feeling that that
victory over that person you just
crushed yeah I don't think rising
Thunder is going to be able to capture
the essence of that and that is what
makes funny game so good sorry to dial
that back but that's I think what makes
you go so exciting is that you you do
have this intimacy when it comes to
combat excellence a bunch of those
videos are available on various YouTube
channels I know Street Fighter John's
have them up and kept is their stuff
there's a couple of other smaller
organizations that have them up there as
well I'm sure you both channel have as
well yeah so if you have any actually if
do you have any suggested matches or
like tournaments that you particularly
enjoyed you're probably watching Street
Fighter a long run I watched most of
them i would say sri fighter for sure
was just crazy this year the the whole
top 8 and some of the matches leading up
to that were just all very amazing
matches just emotionally draining for me
like a lot of them went to the fifth
game and I i vs nemo watching PR raag
almost beat nemo so there's like a whole
bunch of like just watch top a street
butter if you're into Street Fighter at
all like there's a lot of good matches
their awesome suburban teh appreciate
you coming on as ever I will let you get
your ass back to suburbia and Peter
Brown you stick around we got a shot of
a Shenmue in just a second
you